there's been a global semiconductor chip
shortage so from your perspective just
to be interesting to get your expert
analysis of the situation what do you
think are the main reasons and how is
qualcomm being affected and how can it
help
in this and in the future things like it
okay that's a that's a
a big topic of conversation and we only
have five minutes so i'll try i'll try
to be as objective as i can so first
let's talk about what caused it and and
i you know you hear a lot of different
things i will try to put it within the
right context the first thing that
caused it really
is the acceleration of digital
transformation of pretty much
everything in every industry
every industry has been digitally
transformed and as such the amount of
semiconductors that are required is much
larger
just to give you a practical example if
you think about the automotive as an
example
the cars there are you there's cars
there launch a new model launching today
the new model launching today most
likely has 10x the amount of chips off
the prior model and the model is people
working on this coming in next probably
10x that one so you see the amount of
silicon and then billions of things
become smart
more and more data goes to the cloud the
data center grows so the floor for
semiconductor consumptions went up by a
lot then you have things that aggravated
this the pandemic aggravated this there
is a couple trends from the pandemic the
enterprise transformation of the home
the home became an enterprise massive
amount
of upgrades on broadband and iot
the office
uh has changed to the way we work now uh
in including the ability to support
collaboration tools and video
then you have
the
higher demand
for for products doing the
pandemic because people wanted to be
connected people bought new phones and
their tablets and new computers uh new
gaming so all of those things came on
top of that as
the aggravated issue but they're not the
main issue the main issue is
it's actually a
long-term growth of digital so what i'm
hearing you say
is the pandemic was not the cause it was
an aggravation it's an aggravation so
is there a way
we can support as a human civilization
in terms of manufacture in terms of
supply the kind of growth that you're
talking about in devices and so on is
there
high level ideas you can say of what
that's required there
yes and i think that's the second part
of the answer so what's happening now
how are we going to get out of this so
we see a lot of capacity investments put
into place by the industry
you know we had invested a lot with our
suppliers a lot of the suppliers
had made
plans about you know increasing the
capacity industry is planning to double
its total semiconductor manufacturing
capacity within the next
five years an example so that's already
happening and then you see things which
are actually good they're good
uh the initiatives such as the united
states chips act
and now the european chips act the
united states uh chip sacks about uh 52
billion dollars europeans about 43
their goal combined is to get at least
50 percent of the consumption uh
with manufacturing installed within the
u.s and european geographies and that's
also very good that's yet another uh
incentive for more manufacturing
capacity to be built and to be built
with a geographic distributed way which
that's how you play in supply chain so
those those i think are good things so
if anything we learn
through the crisis
is that semiconductor
is important semiconductor companies are
important and we need to invest in
semiconductors
you